I want to introduce you to uh yingjun
who will talk about
um
climate change
and uh
how we can help
and maybe you all can help and maybe at
the end of this talk you will be very
into this and will join uh her on this
journey so
uh Jin young has a is an environmental
scientist
turned data scientist
and has a PHD in environmental science
from U.S Santa Barbara
um yeah I will stop talking here enjoy
the presentation so can you guys hear me
now
okay yeah
thank you guys uh coming to my talk and
good afternoon it's my pleasure here
today in Seattle so it's very meaningful
for me because um here is I got my first
job in Seattle right now I'm working as
a price scientist at the Disco lab which
is a startup and it's provides your
spatial analytics because I'm a
geographer I'm a mental scientist so
we're working on this kind of solution
for big corporate and also non-profit
and my work experience has been from
like Academia big corporate to stop
and this uh three Circle which is a
natural disaster event and ecological
system and also hydrochliment system is
something I focus entire my career and
my interest is about time series
analysis and forecasting and spatial
analysis also some computer vision model
because our staff right now is focusing
on cellular image to do a lot of machine
learning and deep learning model
and here is a free open source and
transparent visualization of carbon
intensity of electricity consumption
around the world maps we call
electricity Maps I don't know if you
guys heard this before
and I heard this like pretty much last
year and I joined the open AI climate
change High custom and then they got
this idea so one of our teams saying
that we want to do something like carbon
coding green coding so we figure out
this data set could be useful so that's
gave me this idea and I dive into this
safe project Journey
and this is could be a part of third
party and open source data
a little bit about agenda today
so we'll talk about why should we care
about this and also energy consumption
measurement so I apologize the first two
part will be very very boring so more
like a energy class in the school and
it's now related to coding here and for
the Serpa will be the open source tool
and this tool will be focus on three one
is a carbon awareness SDK which is
developed by Microsoft and also UBS and
also green software Foundation together
recently they just released the white
paper
and also there's the other one my
favorite one is called co-carbon which
is very easy to use I will do a live
demo and this one will go to a platform
it's called cow
carbon Computing something sorry
I'll look at letter and then we do some
future outlook which is my reflection
about using these tools and how this
could help to find the climate change
sounds good
okay
and so why should we care about this
because we want to do environmental
sustainability so what does that mean it
means the ecological balance in our
planet's natural environment and
conservative nature resource to support
our well-being and the future generation
so that's environmental sustainability
and there's like a social sustainability
and also ecology suspended and economy
has been a bit too
and because uh in the U.N and also ipcc
they plan to reach the Net Zero carbon
emission goal by 2050 so that's why we
need to care about it and how do we do
the mitigation so we do like producing
less carbon dioxide and also using
energy more efficiently and also
choosing electricity over fossil fuels
and also focus on less emission that's
the way we can do about environmental
care sorry
something wrong with my
top um
yeah maybe when it falls asleep okay
okay sorry
my laptop it's kind of old and fall
asleep yeah
and
so because a lot of cooperation inside
transition from
unparent data to data centered cloud
computing so there's like Data Center
and data transmission Network and this
data center and and called Data Center
is actually account for nearly one
percent of energy related Global
greenhouse gas emissions
this will be increased in the future
and major Cloud providers such as liger
other AWS gcp will match their Cloud
energy consumption with carbon free
energy through Power purchase agreement
so this is like a agreement to do like
carbon neutral measurement
so the way we care about it is the
carbonize the green so it's the carbon
lighter energy consumption
so how we do it here is the example
about supply and demand over time for
grip with the missed generates deck so
you can see the green one is from solar
and so this is a example from the
California so there are times in
California where those is oversupply of
solar power in the middle of the day and
then the clean uterus is being
discovered so that's actually the orange
one
and consumption more electricity at
those time will cause no additional
emission so that's the way we can do by
using clean energy and you can see the
gray one is actually cold and I believe
it's a fossil fuel that kind of types of
energy
that's a way we can do more like a less
emission and using more clean energy
so there's a turn in a white paper they
mentioned about its carbon awareness so
what is carbon awareness is doing more
when more energy comes from low carbon
source so such as like a energies are
clean and also doing less when more
energy comes from high carbon source
okay so photosho is cold and also like
like I mentioned from the graph it's
more like a Time shifting so this can
shifting by ultimate impact by shifting
water from one location has maybe like
in the middle of time using solar and
then the other time zone different can
use in the other time zones solar so
it's more like location based margin
carbon intensity for each of the data
center
and this also indicates a location shift
so this can optimize impact by shifting
roller between this location
and also demand shaping surrounding
software so it does more when the truth
is clean and less when it's dirty so
it's about how we use software and how
we do the demand
so there's a way so this actually a
website for another Pi data talk in
Berlin there's about green coating so
they do the energy consumption
measurement so here that's a very
important idea it's about carbon
intensity so what is carbon intensity
it's about amount of emission of carbon
dioxide release per unit
and there's some other way you can
generate like from electronical from AC
and DC and also software such as CPU
usage like if you use the software
Hardware like 100 CPU then it mean much
more carbon dioxide
and there's an extensor on the chips too
and they focus on this with about
different measurements about CPU per
code and also software model capacity
reading um mean board so that's
basically how you control your Hardware
chosen into your software
and here is another concept so this
campsite is about a software carbon
intensity specification
and this is proposed by Microsoft UBS
and green silver Foundation again with
code SCI specification
so this equals to energy consumed by a
software system measured in kilowatts
and multiply by location marginal
marginal carbon emission like we
mentioned before and carbon emine per
kilowatt of energy and this will plus an
embedding body of the services like the
hardware system
unless always wrongly so per rate it's a
function Union which is how the
application scale so like per extra user
or per API call so when you call the
check GPT API and that's something you
will emit the carbon
so that's how I'm going to talk
so have you guys used the jgbt before
raise your hand
wow pretty much the Forum using the 3gbt
so we know like jgbt is original from
gpt3 so when doing a 2gbt for the
training is that approximately about
using
1287 milliwatts and produce 500 52 tons
of carbon dioxide so that's a lot right
so what about running the chair gbt so
when we ask a question so how much
carbon produced from jgbt can you guys
answer me I mean anyone want to guess
sure
five thousand okay let's see
so jgb's daily carbon footprint to be
could be like 23.04
kilogram carbon dioxide and this is from
ml carbon dioxide impact calculator and
this is a hyperlink
and every day you run the jgpt could be
approximately about 0.2 percent annual
carbon footprint of Denmark
and if you're using the jgbt annually so
the carbon footprint will approximately
about 76 percent of Denmark for the
whole year
so that's kind of a lot right so
are we supposed to use the jbd now I
don't know
okay that's something we can guess about
how we use the software for like carbon
emission and maybe we can use a better
time and better location with clean
energy
okay so let's dive into more coding pop
so here is like carbon over SDK so this
SDK is again developed by Microsoft and
also green silver Foundation
and their goal is trying to do be
environmental responsible and mitigate
climate change and reduce greenhouse gas
emission
so what they will do is actually perform
with a different shifting and time
demand demand so that's actually the
carbon intensity we just introduced and
then
there's a different times of day you can
shift from the guide
coat into the green energy so like clean
energy
and how they do is just like optimize
experience from this and also this can
Implement a carbon over Computing so
which means that the lowest possible
carbon emission
and here is there
actually open source link from GitHub
and they actually have three or four
features one is a carbon footprint
estimation tools and also adding the
carbon data inside this API so actually
they not only provide their own data but
also from what time and also the ear
trusting Maps we just saw
and that's one feature the other feature
is a coding portfolio and optimization
like we mentioned we can optimize our
code and do much more portfolio for
coding
and in the green software Foundation
they also do a green coding best
practice with Microsoft and the other
partner at the time
and also the integrate with the clean
energy which means a renewable energy
source
so here I'm going to show you guys how
this web API doing and they actually
have a YouTube video here
so let's play the YouTube video
and today I will take you through some
quick steps to run the SDK on your local
machine as a local web site
to get started go to the prince after
Foundation repository on GitHub and look
for the capital ytk project
once there copy the kit clone URL switch
to a local terminal
start training the Repository
you should then see a list of folder
appearing on the side
of which we are interested in browsing
to the web API folder so we can run the
API from there
so let's pass to that folder by going
into carbon or SDK slash SRC slash
government aware dot web API SRC folder
in there we will use the dotnet core SDK
already pencil on the machine to run the
API from that local folder
once the project is compiled you will
see a URL in the output that you can use
in your local browser
if you fixed with swagger to access the
Swagger definition of the endpoint
once loaded you will see a list of all
the endpoints available by the web API
the as well as a comprehensive
documentation of each one of those
endpoints
each endpoint offers a concise
description of what the endpoint offers
a list of available parameters in their
descriptions
and the ability to try this out straight
from the browser
let's give it to go straight away by
proceeding to a location shifting some
value
where we are looking to understand
which of a few locations offers the best
company emission at a given time
so in this case we won't be specifying
any time which means they will run for
right now
for the given your locations
also note that those locations are Azure
regions
so here we have UK South North Europe
after not sharp again actually sorry
click on execute and it will tell you
which location offers the best carbon
um
or emission rating
in this case we have 59 grams per
kilowatt hour
feel free to explore all the other
endpoints available
I hope you found this video useful
clinics probation and good luck with
your projects and thank you for watching
yeah thank you and that's kind of like a
short video about like presentation for
the carbon coding
and right now we dive into the other one
so it's cold carbon which is another
open source package whereby measure the
energy consumption of computing device
so using filters such as like Hardware
electricity consumption and data center
location to estimate carbon emission so
you can see there's a figure here it's
like a GPU and also CPU and also your
rent so this is your Hardware energy
consumption multiplied by the regional
carbon intensity of electricity
and this is actually an open source
package rebound Miller which is a
Academia Institute and I personally like
this one because easy and also I would
do a light demo letter and
this is a python base and also it's IAP
or base which is we just mentioned about
the chips and different hardware and
also supports the Nvidia GPU
so basically when you have a deep
learning model like tensorflow here you
just use Franco carbon import emission
and then they'll give you some each of
the rent and Emissions I'll demonstrate
later
so here then I only give you some idea
about the code in there but also give
you a dashboard so this dashboard will
give you about the location and how much
you can come from here and they're
basically meta info
so basically that's kind of a dashboard
and now it's another demo time
so this is several lines of code
from emission trigger and tracker
emission start and stop
so let's do a live demo here
so can you guys see my screen so this is
a vs go
and I do a model this is a CNN model
so when I hit the python
and model that pie
so you can see
kind of thinking right now okay cold
carbon
it comes full CPU and then this is my
laptop
and there's a file already download
verified
so it's taking a little bit of time here
so can give you energy concern for Rams
4.63 Watts
so this is how it took and then because
this model is not very efficient
optimized so
it probably will take about
like an hour I think I run this before
and so you can see you found this
running
testing with your own model
they will give you some more like very
easily accessible idea about your own
hardware and the carbon emission
so
that's it and then I give you a sound
like screenshot when I run before
so here is to send information
it's still running
and when I do the like Interruption and
I give you the count so for all CPU the
ocpu power for about 42.5
what and that's kind of the way we're
doing after I do the stopping so right
now my background still running with the
cold cover
program yeah
so that's basically the co-carbon and I
like this one better than the other one
yeah the other one is more like web
browser but you can explore on your
spare time
and next we're going to curl compute
inside
so here's the other
API is called call
carbon footprint and this is a open
source tool to estimate energy use so
kilowatts per hour and carbon emission
like metric tones for usual emission
from the public cloud
and they give you this kind of dashboard
and the feature for them is actually
have input data from different cloud
provider and types of size of resource
such as virtual machine storage bucket
and database from each of the data sense
Center region
and then this gives you the estimate for
the energy use and Associated carbon
emission of the results you choose
and then the each of the cow providers
such as Azure AWS will have their own
commencement to renewable energy so
that's basically you choose how you use
the clean energy and do the carbon
offset initiate
and this will give you the overall
estimation about carbon emission
associated with your organization's
cloud storage
Cloud usage so for my current
organization we're also using a lot of
clouds from like AWS and also used to be
gcp yeah but not the other here
so here's more about demo
let's go into the worry browser
and
so you can go through the car carbon
footprint here
so there's an old provider
so when I do just that Azure because
we're in Microsoft
and then
could come we have a full
fire account and Service is like
one virtual machine
and we can see one month how Azure is
doing maybe there's no data but three
months
or six months
maybe a year let's see so local usage
for Azure is nice
isometric tones and from
May of last year until right now pretty
much right now there's a time difference
for image emitting the carbon dioxide
found the cow usage
and there's also Coast
you can see the coast here
pretty much around like
1.3 dollar to two dollars
and then kilowatts per hours
pretty similar
and then you accumulate emissions at 29
metric tone carbon
dioxide emission
this is a directly compared to from New
York to London
and they also give you a carbon
intensity map like electricity Maps so
this you can see the low intensity is
around the European area
and in our United States there's more
like a neutral
but in the between for frontal lobe and
then high in the between
for the high intensity use a mostly
carbon it's actually found
China south of China and also India and
also Australia and South Africa
found like Azure so it's very
interesting
and in this playphone you can also play
around with AWS and also gcp yeah United
and
the way they do it is actually using the
method
calculate with operation emission and
also in body emission that's the
hardware emission
for the manufacturer for data center
and
that's basically they took your building
data from your Cloud usage and also
multiply by some other
detail log here
with energy estimate watch hours so
basically you have a compute watts per
hour is equal to the CPU hours and also
average multiplied by average hours
and also the GPU so basically the taking
account about hardware and Storage
and networking for memory so this is all
about the call
and let's see so carbon
estimate from gcp is different than the
AWS azure because they have different
grades estimation here
so that's the method they're doing
okay so let's go back to our slice
so key takeaway here so energy
consumption that carbon awareness
capability is measured by all these open
source tool and I believe there's a much
more open source tool out there
and the good or bad of using ml model or
AI like gbt it's all the time like
depends on you you want to use that or
save our planet
and understanding the master and find
the results necessary to reduce the
carbon intensity
for our works software stack so we can
write more efficient code and also
choose much more clean energy
so here's my kind of reflection
so how much energy consumption will be
converted into water and electricity
bill from each of our soft server
like execution or maybe like corporates
software usage
and Cloud usage and also how much water
will be cooling down for the data center
because right now we only care about the
energy usage but also I think there's a
water usage too but there's like a
recycled water but I think water is now
like Infinity resource too so we need to
think about that way in the future and
how much energy and water could be saved
by using this suspendable Computing tool
so I don't know that's a good reflection
a future direction for for us to think
and also finally how much carbon
emission will be reduced by using this
tool or other platform that's the way we
need to think about
so this is all the resource I plug in so
the daily Mentos Professor sustainable
Computing has a ladder to look and
there's a green coding green silver
foundation and also the white paper from
Microsoft is here
and open suspendable technology has a
lot of Open Source packages for each of
the environmental resource
and thank you and here's my contact info
and this is the code I'm just demoing in
my GitHub
and finally I want to acknowledge so I
got a courage to submit the talk here
because I joined the pi data Global
conference to be the impact scholar so
this recognize about diversity and
equality and inclusion so being the
woman in the like environmental science
sustainability and Computing this is a
very like challenging Rule and career
route so I think they give us a weekly
talk and about giving a talk in either
Pi data or meet up it's very encouraging
us to boost our confidence and also
share our knowledge with the audience
thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much
um any questions
okay let me bring the microphone I'm
almost tall we need to record those
questions
so so your calculations you demonstrated
uh partway through the talk today the
actual calculations where there was very
you know detailed I'm just wondering
I'm a big fan of the the work by on the
ethereum virtual machine in the way that
the ethereum yellow paper
um
calculated or
attempted to calculate how many how much
was required for each compute
step
with regards to the ethereum and
virtual coin Solutions I'm just
wondering is there is there any work
that goes sort of between between this
this body of work on on carbon Computing
calculations and and sort of that
earlier work I think it was by I
forgotten who who wrote the uh the
ethereum the the the yellow paper but
it's kind of it's it's on GitHub it's a
very it's an excellent paper
so your question inside is there any
paper about a theory for at least carbon
Computing or I guess that's one question
and the other question is is the is the
is there some sort of parallels between
the work is it sort of is this work on
this your scope of your work is very is
both detailed and very high level you
know considering the the cloud computing
the big graphs whereas probably in terms
of Engineers and scientists
we in order to make some impact on the
cloud computing we need to kind of
perhaps program something into our
applications to minimize the app the
energy that it uses yeah yeah
so I've seen in a
doctor Davies
must blogger yeah he actually was a
professor here so this guy and then he
had some paper about not only carbon
Computing and also some equations and
different data centers and also like
water consumption too so basically if
you go into this guy's blog you can find
much more resource and I can actually
show you something here
and
and that guy was a professor but right
now it's a staff CTO
okay so it's called suspendable
Computing and then
there's a way for article about carbon
emission data cycle AWS and
other
other provider and there's paper for
full paying for data center
I don't know if this answer your first
question
and the second question is using is
payroll and I need to much more like
software to minimize the emission
I think that's doable and I think
basically you can so this one's still
running so
so keyboard into it I think basically
you can build upon this um cold carbon
emission tracker for each of your small
software you can see how efficient to do
it so that's why I say this is my
favorite go-to tool yeah
oh carbon using okay yeah
I think maybe there's some other way
from the this burger and then we can
talk about it later yeah
hi
um so I just had a question about more
of a general question just about using
data science in general to fight climate
change more broadly like about more
topics and just competing centers I was
wondering if you could speak to that
uh so your question is that data science
in general to find climate change and
will be different ways or in terms of
like focusing on the data center I'm
just wondering yeah so I'm just
wondering how it can be applied more
broadly towards like I don't know
um just the energy Grid in general like
or just
um you know people's decisions to use
cars versus other things how can it
affect people's decisions more generally
to
so I think this uh can affect people
from their personal carbon footprint so
from this is also just like corporate
software usage or personal software
usage from each of the carbon Computing
before
our daily life is actually like we can
grab from maybe we call every day and
then we see how much carbon we use and
we tracker like for example I travel
from San Francisco Bay to here so I also
like took some like responsible for
carbon emissions or carbon footprint so
that's the way we can track to compare
like I just demoed as a cow carbon
footprint here there's some kind of
comparison and then we can aggregate to
be our personal carbon footprint and
this can make decisions maybe like
maybe I won't take an airplane maybe I
took um the trend to Seattle will be
better but it's taking much more longer
time and that's the way I think could be
not only focused on data center but also
focus on our daily life
I don't know if
um answer to your question
I think I'm more interested in how this
could influence politicians you know
like our decision makers legislators and
how we can inform them with data like
how that what that process looks like
you know like okay how it could be used
to fight climate change on a more uh
Global political Arena
I think we can aggregate into this data
and then show where is the hotspot and
then
compare with the um like I said so my
expert is kind of like natural disaster
and we know if there's a much more Wi-Fi
and also have some carbon emission
related so we can think about is there
correlation in between and then this can
influence about like the political
management about carbon emission yeah
so just to address the previous question
I'm not actually involved in a lot of
environmental stuff myself but if you
want to be a data scientist for good in
that direction join your local Sierra
Club
um the Sierra Club sort of nationally
does some really really detailed
calculations and stuff and if you join
the club and get to know people and you
can find out places you can help and
that would be a great way to get started
um generally speaking in local politics
they are crying out for people who can
understand data and they don't even know
what questions to ask so there's huge
opportunities to do good
that's cool thank you yeah
thank you very much